اضطرينا ننزل جنب الاموات وبنستنى يومنا
عشان نكون معاهم ايش اقول لك يا امي ايش
احكي لك لا لقم عارفين ناكل لا نوم عارفين
النام لا الله
يعزك حمام ابسط حقوق الانسان
مافيش ابسط حقوق الانسان الميه
مافيش حالنا ومشينا هان جينا لقينا ناس
قاعده بتنصب خير في رفح حوالين المقبره
وقعدنا عند المقبره ه اجينا شردنا من
الزحمه البلد احنا بتنا واليوم احنا جاين
جينا نجاور الناس الاموات
القبور قم شايف احنا جوا المقبره
باعتبارنا داخل المقبره دفنو بالحياه
اساسا احنا ميتين هيك باعتبارنا
مدفونين يعني شعور بقشعر البدن واحنا في
خيمه مش البرد قتلنا اصلا ميت من البرد
اما حياه كلها معناه وتعب خوف والصغار
خايفين اصلا مرقوا هجت من هنا يدفنوهم
والصغار خايفين وانا انا كبيره
[موسيقى]
ومرعوبه عندنا صحين من تعب يعني بنخاف من
السحم اللي شنا وبيجوا الجد اخوان بطلعوا
بخف بطلع وخاف اش الشاحنه دفنت 70 واحد
خفنا احنا انظلمنا كثير فيها هذه احنا
مدنيين وما قنا اي ذنب باللي صار واحنا
اللي دفعنا الثمن والله اولادنا تعقدوا
انهبلوا حتى عندهم شويه امبارح يعني نزلوا
الجثث المتحلله اللي عند اليهود كانوا
سارقين لهم فتره ايش بده يصير في هيك
اطفال بعد هيك عليهم العوض اولادنا
اولادنا عليهم العوض هذا كنا كمان واحنا
في مصر يجي مثلا في اول رجب نطلع نزور
المقابر يسموها طلعه رجب نطلع اروح ازور
الاموات اللي هم بيعزوا علينا لكن اني انا
اعيش جنب
المقابر هذا كله انا ما تخيلتش ان انا
اعيش في اللحظه هذه لكن ايش اعمل وين اروح
ها اخر اخر الدنيا
عندي e